[Applause]
booker's lowest scoring average
is against the denver nuggets just 15
and a half points per game
throughout his career three of 18.
as you look at the shooting tonight has
been very good for both teams
into the lane up and in looking for the
cutter dozier
wide open and he missed the layup
he was so open i don't think he realized
this guy now bridges for three back the
other way and it's a five-point switch
yeah
that's bad morris shooting just 31
from three-point land and way
way out is cameron johnson
[Music]
chris paul he makes that shot in his
sleep
last time these two teams played back on
february 8th of last year nuggets won
that one
117 108 that was at phoenix as that jump
shot
goes in
and paul tries to draw the foul by
kicking out the leg
galloway that's good but the nuggets not
getting much scoring from anybody else
paul inside ayton puts it in
where we're getting killed teams are
shooting 43 percent
against us now booker
tough shot at the baseline and he hits i
guess we're trailing 38-37 then phoenix
scored 14
straight points to open up the lead
52-37
a long-range three that's good
he's got the bucket and the thought long
shots long rebounds
[Applause]
payne in the lane and he drops it up and
in
10-point lead
[Applause]
[Music]
booker right to the goal the nuggets
defense uh
that time not on the same page it's man
up
the he just goes for the ball nice on
the side and
maybe he thought there was help right
there
[Applause]
[Music]
booker from sizing up green
lane and he puts it up and in nice play
booker
that was his eighth rebound if you keep
it score at home
now chris paul and paul
knocks it in
good switch by barton oh barton had it
booker shoots it
and hits the three martin headed his
hand and gave it right back to it
oh my gosh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chris paul into the screen and roll pole
fading baseline hits it
is his teammate so excited they jump out
and they give him a flat tire
this is why you get chris paul because
he can always get his shot
and he's not afraid the moment's not too
big a little hesitation a little step
back
look at that eighteen's right there for
the tip if he does miss
see gary ran right into the screen and
now it's there's no pressure coming from
behind
yeah he was actually double-teamed on
that pass from donovan donovan was wide
open had a
nice little mid-range in there second
turnover chris paul on a step back
rattles in his fifth point and there's
that corner three
we've been looking for and you'd like to
see that flame on early
jordan clarkson not wasting any time
devin booker on a stop and go
drive to bring it up because
we see offensive improvement from rudy
every single year i think right now it's
about being in the right place as devin
booker
goes strong to the basket watch this
by devin booker you talk about a
professional score he sees
the court the lane open up and takes
that opportunity
gets by jordan clarkson
the rebound comes out to phoenix and
they're off and running
galloway to booker tough shot as he
really fell out of bounds that's four
boards in six minutes
for deandre ayton chris paul
off balance shot we've seen it for years
he floats away
to the baseline and hits the shot that
flagrant one call i mean he could have
gone either way he could have been a
little more frustrated
but for him to have the ability to play
that kind of defense
quickly to booker back to crowder
wide open three up and in pain showing
some some range ten points that's the
spread
jazz oh ten turnovers that shot
softly put to bed by mikhail bridges
an easy basket when you've got a foul
you can give up
looker forces that shot out nice soft
touch by the big man
ayton and a fresh 14 on the clock
chris paul behind the back cam
johnson and a quick five for cam
just a beautiful sequence got the three
inside shot bounces in and one booker
will be at the line
for a three-point opportunity that's the
best defense
you're playing against a professional
scorer there you're royce o'neil who is
a great on ball defender but right here
booker kind of throws that
lower shoulder into roy lin's in on
booker jazz need the ball back shot
clock at seven
booker on a drive now the three is away
good
and coached chris paul for that one
season in two thousand
[Music]
nice spinning shot right there and
that's put in by mikel bridges
comes booker
again with a little move from the newly
instated cameron pain
off a little bit
in charge this is over hearts nice shot
by
dario scharich payne will drive and kick
it outside
carter back on top johnson galloway
got it fouled on the play by williamson
really been an n1
but look at the size difference here
between ayton and williamson
booker johnson campaign
look at the nice ball rotation jackson
three
cam jackson from outside his first
basket tonight
nba.com slash pick them to play for free
nice feed inside and what a great jam by
bridges
all the big names have been quiet
tonight reggie in that regard
that pass had some serious gas on it
with paul feeding in
[Applause]
paul's got the mismatch works on zion
williamson the three
is good for chris paul biggest lead of
the game right now for phoenix
[Applause]
crowder with two over ball
wow how about that
especially during the playoffs shot
clock running down
little step back three coming off that
most
improved player a season ago and has
taken the next leap though
the numbers won't show that tonight he
has taken another lead
booker can't get it but ayden does
need three bench points for the pelican
three charge three
5g above the rim
the drake uh women's team with a drive
inside williamson
he couldn't complete it here comes payne
back to johnson with the wide open drive
in the lane
hanson reaching in we'll pick it up
in the nba now in his fourth season here
is
carter on the wing
[Applause]
wow boy luke walton found the right
button to press after that
timeout well he trusts the bench first
and foremost mark
good point as chris paul stops the
hemorrhaging temporarily
and luke walden as has been his custom
here
well going back to the preseason doug
he's not afraid to use a lot of bodies
as booker
gets the bucket and the foul underneath
john holmes pushes it in and
look at buddy i mean he's he's working
down there does he get him with the body
yeah
maybe but the point is he's putting
pressure on
[Applause]
making booker work for everything here
in the early going with
facing up on white side shot clock down
to seven good help by white side out to
payne
[Applause]
tried to quick shoot and does white side
he got rid of it before whiteside could
get his bearing
ayton on the post up kicks it back out
to johnson
whiteside got a hand and a little bit
too much after that and then johnson has
put the ball
in the hole from behind the arc now puts
it on the deck and gets the three-point
play
maybe the conventional as the point
guard brings the ball up the floor he
has to process and digest that
information try to get them into
something and that takes a little bit of
time
oh boy galloway dug right at the end of
the shot clock
very motivated to silence some of his
doubters
[Applause]
and a potential perhaps four-point play
you see kicked out out the burden a good
contest
just a smart veteran move right
joseph a good on-ball defender guarding
booker
johnson into the paint the hoop and the
foul
that's gonna go against bagley you're
gonna see him he's gonna come in
shot blocker go right into the chest
come through the arms and deliver off
the glass
just a great move
and bagley here's paul guarded by joseph
in his stance
paul probing comes out the other side
for the jump shot to run on them tonight
fox left it short
booker speaking of fast breaks and one
fouled
by buddy hill they were going to cut the
paint off and that's what they've tried
to do is you see booker get out in the
open court and
gives buddy a little stare afterwards
but
this is a sun's team that you said it we
might see him go 11d
it'd be important for guys to be ready
and get their work in
booker in his bag deep in his back
knocked down the mid-range and booker
scoops up the loose ball
pull-up three is good for booker
diving to the cup and offensive foul
clearly and i love what devin booker he
named first team all nba in either his
first or second year
since tim duncan back in 1999.
booker hangs and finishes beautifully
done by devin booker now nine points
hit a couple of shots though finished
with
seven in the quarter but devin i don't
think we give enough credit to ricky
with ricky rubio and the job he did in
phoenix
leading this team i think ultimately the
best moves was made by the lakers
winning a championship
crowder trailing nice feed and the slam
by
smith do you put yourself in position to
be effective
shot clock at five payne gets into the
paint and a great finish there
assist for doncic he averaged nine per
game last year good for third in the nba
here's booker with the hanging finish 13
points for devin booker his first
bucket of the second quarter 15 shots
bridges had 15 booker 13 for the suns
who have an eight point lead
in the season opener in game one 38
in game six although the mavs just
didn't have enough
as chris paul gets his first points as a
son
last time chris paul had this matchup he
missed the three this time
so allow me to have this dance shot
clock down to five it did not hit the
rim
and payne this time gets past cleva
as we talk about the pain move
[Applause]
booker trying to shake cleeba now backs
up
cleva meets him out near the hash mark
shot clock down to five
here comes the double booker gives it up
timers at two
cam johnson has to let it flock all the
work that they have done throughout
getting back to the bubble and certainly
here with this
quick start to another season cam
johnson tough drive and able to knock
down the runner
able to get deep into the paint and put
it in on a good defender
sometimes you gotta be willing to take
what the defense gives you that's
cameron payne knocks down the jump shot
jalen brunson and that pass hit the back
of javon carter's an
excellent defender galloway
cans a three and a foul a four point
chance
down shooter and he's locked and loaded
when he enters the ball game
jaylen brunson off with a turnover great
games a lot of awesome
basketball to watch
[Applause]
turned over by the mavs as johnson gets
the steal
the step through in the bucket on the
other end
paul with that pull-off jumper that's
sweet and the latest three
look at the leadership on the floor and
off
matters most you need a basket shot
clock at five big possession here for
the suns booker with two
hits over brunson he puts his team in
position and puts his home run
hit in position to take a big shot
great defense by jalen brunson but
better offense by devin booker